we got to spit you all up into four
groups transport you to the search areas
[Music]
it's just I want things to go back to
the way they were before they are not
gonna go back to the way they were you
make do with what's left
Bridget it's 8:20 get your ass home I'm
not your personal babysitter I need you
to watch him Bridget come home on a
night air holder don't do anything
stupid said work Bridget I don't know
where the hell she is
it's been three days since we last saw
Bridget we have a photo and all of our
patrol cars she's out there we're gonna
find it this is a mother's worst
nightmare
you have to eat something deaf you're
scaring us I need to know what happened
to my daughter I am begging
to know that your daughter's out there
somewhere and she's calling for you you
can't get to we just want to find her
and bring her home
you're a great mother that never changed
I miss my daughter it's over she's never
coming back get out of my house
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm on things go back to the way they
were before they are not gonna go back
to the way they were you make do with
what's left
[Music]
you